soit paru je puis vous voir fréquemment
audit famille de bosses compliqué voyez
un petit extrait du film très attendu
qui est à la fiche depuis jeudi soir
dans quelques salles le meilleur
ciellement depuis hier soir par tous et
mafia inc
réalisé par daniel grou alias podz qui
est avec moi ce matin bonjour alors
c'est une grosse semaine la s'élancer
s'élancer ouais ben oui il ya eu
beaucoup de promo et la première balle
avant première ça sent bon et la réponse
du public est un procès public à date
c'est super c'est très bon il y avait
vraiment critique jeu très content on se
déplacer au cinéma en parlons du
scénario c'est un film qui est inspiré
du livre mafia inc qui a été écrit par
andré cédilot et andré noël mais vous en
avez fait une adaptation c'est pas
nécessairement ce qui s'est passé au
québec dans la mafia alors si c'est pas
un documentaire on s'est inspiré des
événements du lait on s'est inspiré de
la famille ce qu'avait fait mais on a
inventé le pro famille on a augmenté
notre propre heures nos deux pros
famille et quand j'ai donc on parle pas
du tout notre terre non c'est pas bien
nous on te dit pas fermé mon pote comme
t il des événements qui sont arrivés
l'opération policière qui était au
centre des années leur le fait que les
gars y avait rassemblé tous les gangs
ensemble s'associent dans ce qu'ils
lisent et mac sur mon film mais en gros
si c'est nous notre famille non c'est un
choix aides avaient d'abord pris vos
distances comme ça de la vraie histoire
on voulait on voulait faire notre propre
film anglais on voulait faire notre
propre histoire on attend inventer nos
propres
little agissent en vue reprenait pour
différentes séries policières dont à
19,2
alors c'est vraiment un univers qui
étouffe facile on dirait si roger je
sais pas mais parce que c'est des gens
qui sont placés dans des situations
extrêmes ou chaud puis je suis curieux
de voir comment ils s'en sortent
si j'ai trouvé ici une âme un long
travail que les policiers puis les
criminels pas mal la même personnalité
jusqu'à notre choix voulons bien choisi
un autre côté il ya comme une jambe de
parenté chaussures c'est super
intéressant
je me soumets tellement dans l'eau
chaude qui voit comment ils vont s'en
sortir la tension est très forte le
voyons toulon du fir leclerc nous dit
tout à l'heure qu'à la fin il ya une
scène choc pour le public à la fin une
dernière scène s'est passée choc
une telle idée de cette classe est de
laisser avec un sourire aussi ça peut
être sourire en plus j'en appelais
roenick mais c'est de laisser le site
public sur la commune de saïx que je
suis est que le public québécois est un
grand acteur a été renié sergio
castellitto que vous allez recruter pour
faire le parrain pour faire le point
ouais
est-ce que ça a été facile de convaincre
je suis pas facile et le scénario puis à
messi de suite fait que pillay avait vu
mes films mais ce
mini film fait que oui j étais vraiment
intéressé en lisant le scénario c'était
très fort et puis message est à 10
rencontrés à rome puis ç'a cliqué en
moins que marc andré grondin aussi ans
qui joue un rôle de gars qui jouent
l'électron libre sombre c'est lui qui
perturbe tous les deux clans celui qui
veut faire sa marque détruit tout sur
son passage
et pensez vous comme un réalisateur dans
une entrevue qu'on a réalisé un peu plus
tôt cette semaine avec alex pris le camp
tu te fais offrir un rôle qui va être un
rôle de l'opposition s'est réalisé par
quelqu'un tu connais avec qui te fait
l'argument ça a été une de mes plus
belles expériences de jeu c'est
sécurisant de savoir que tu vas avoir un
bon capitaine de bateau pour tourner à
qui tu vois même sur le mantrand
ailleurs que tu pensais 30 et au final
pas il m'a même toujours un petit peu à
l'extérieur de maçon de confort qui
aiment caste généralement pour des
affaires pourquoi je serai pas qu'à
citer avec d'autres réalisateurs a lancé
ça permet justement de créer des
personnages qui sont très éloignées -
puis je pense que ça fait de moi un
meilleur acteur suite à ma collaboration
avec lui c'était jour est aussi plaisant
de le diriger lui j'imagine que oui
c'est toujours oui c'est aussi présents
team avec mark henry c'est un gars qui
je pense qu'ils ont faim pas quel point
il peut être bon et comme très humbles
face à city et très je veux faire passer
l'équipe que tout venant et très pro
dans ce sens là mais en même temps il ya
comme il beaucoup mieux et beaucoup dans
le moment beaucoup plus dans son émotion
qui osent de l'essai de faire croire aux
autres puisqu'il ose la couleur du même
je pense que ça c'est fascinant à
regarder puis moi je suis un grand
comédien puis je veux travailler avec
ces titres est jouissif pour moi la mepi
l'ifa 2010 vient dick qui deviendra
meilleur comédien mais il y fait de moi
un meilleur résultat
conclusion ça
à la fiche journées froides comme
aujourd'hui c'était une belle occasion
qui a été fait pour les grands écrans
aussi fait que gère de voir le système
spectacle fait que je me suis fière de
voir comment les gens vont réagir
merci ne vois pas un bon succès ok merci